- Like a lot of people,
you dealt with stagefright.
I didn't know that in the beginning.
- Oh yeah.
- I had no idea.
- You don't have any stagefright.
I know. You're very, you're like-
- It's not that I'm...
It's not that I'm...
I mean, I'm a fair amount of confident.
I just mean like we're probably
gonna screw up though sometimes.
So like, whatever.
- You can't be perfect.
I know.
- Yeah. I think I just have
such a low bar expectation wise.
(audience laughs)
I'm like, I mean,
I'm gonna do my best.
And I feel like sometimes it happens,
and you have nights where you're like,
"I did amazing."
And you have nights where you're like,
"Why am I-
- Yeah. Why-
- Why did people pay for this?
- (Shania laughs) "Why
do people pay for this?"
- (Kelly laughs) Yeah.
- No. I think my-
- How did you get over that?
- Well it started more just because
I was singing in bars from
the age of eight years old.
Very intimidating environment.
And everybody's already drunk,
and they're falling everywhere.
- [Kelly] At eight?
- Yeah.
Cigarettes, you know, it just wasn't...
And I think it was more...
(Shania bursts into
laughter) Yes, that's me.
- Little bitty. Little bitty Shania.
- In bars. And so I think
I learned very young
to put on a front, a mask of like,
"Okay, you know, I'm up
here and I'm professional."
- Yeah.
- And you know,
and, but I was petrified.
I was so uncomfortable.
And I think it just stayed with me.
Never really finding my
comfort zone out there
for a long, long time.
I'm in a way better place now.
I don't know what happened.
I think many things happened,
but I grew up, I guess.
But very recently I'm much
more comfortable with it now.
I just see things differently.
- Yeah.
- But whoa. No, no.
For many, many, many, many years
till like I said, very recently,
it was always very (indistinct).
- I always feel sorry.
I know a lot, a lot of artists
actually struggle with that.
And I'm like,
I don't know if I'd go
out on stage and do it.
I think that you're brave.
If I ever felt like that,
I don't think I would follow through.
- It's torture.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It really is torture
to have that anxiety.
- And when I get nervous,
my stomach does this thing
where-
- Yeah. What happens,
do you get cramps?
- Well it's kind of like
a bridesmaid scenario.
(Kelly and the audience laugh)
It's like, you know, you're like,
"Oh my gosh, is this
gonna happen on stage?"
Like your horse.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
I get, I'm just saying,
my stomach, when I get really nervous,
that's what happens.
- Uh-oh.
- Like my stomach just turns.
- That kicks in? Uh-oh.
- Yeah. So what am I gonna do?
Yeah. No.
- I mean a lot of people do,
you know, vomit before they go on stage.
- I know.
- And I know, it's a reaction.
But I did learn from a very young age,
the mind over matter.
You know, put the mask on-
- Yeah.
- Get out there, and nobody should see
that you're, what you're really feeling.
So I was, I got good at that very young,
and managed it, but, oh, oh, oh no.
Very scary feeling.
- I'm glad that you don't get it now,
'cause you're so awesome live.
I think that's what's
so awesome about you,
is you're very welcoming.
You know what I'm saying,
even if you're not right-
- Talk about miss welcoming herself.
- No. I think that that's very,
that's what is so captivating.
You're like, even if you do mess up,
it's like whatever, everybody messes up.
I messed up like 10 times today already.
Like, it happens, it's fine.
- You have to be okay with that.
- Yeah.
- It's kind of like, you know,
the people that learn
a language more quickly
are the ones that are not
afraid to make mistakes
as they're learning it.
Otherwise, you never, you
never practice it out loud.
You never, you know, put it,
- Not afraid to look stupid or something.
- You're not afraid to look stupid.
- You have to be, you
have to really be ready.
And listen, on stage,
if you hit the wrong note,
you forget the words,
you do look stupid,
but your fans are there
because they love you,
and it's a mutual respect
thing so it's fine.
- Even if it's not every night,
it just happens every once in a while.
That's why I guess I
don't, I don't get it.
'Cause I'm like, I'm bound
to suck a lot sometimes.
It's gonna happen, so.
- You do not.
You are so great live.
You're amazing. You're just one of these
such incredible singers of our time.
(audience applauds)
- Oh, you're, you're very nice.
- I honestly though,
I think that's why I like
listening to you too,
is like, it's just
listening to the artists
that like, you're not doing
it 'cause you have to,
you're doing it 'cause you love it,
and there's a difference, you know.
You're not doing it as
'cause it's just a job.
You sound like you love what you do,
and you're all in.
Like your whole body. I love that.